hey everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is
the Ingram angle and look I was on a
flight to La when I saw the news and I
thought look as much as I needed the
break I could not let tonight pass given
the importance of this moment now there
are two big stories we're going to hit
over the next hour first confirming what
we've been telling you now for I think
it's like well over a year there's a new
Coalition of Voters forming in the
United States who are turning away from
the bleakness and despair of the
Democrat Party and toward a more
populous pro-america agenda led by
Donald Trump more on that later and then
of course the big news out of
Cambridge you can't say we didn't warn
them that's the focus of tonight's
angle with each passing day that Ms gay
remains in office the reputation and
credibility of Harvard is damaged tell
Ms gay to resign and tell the MIT
president Sally cornbluth to do the same
and if they don't resign fire them
the truth is all four of those College
presidents who had come before Congress
and then seemed to have trouble
condemning genocide of Jews they should
have been forced to step down and by the
way the lawyers who briefed them fired
but only youens Liz Mill was shown the
door as you recall and I thought to
myself if these women were thick enough
to have said what they said then why
would anyone have been surprised that at
least one of them wouldn't be stupid
enough to commit academ
fraud and the accusations of plagiarism
against Claudine gay they started
trickling out slowly and you know there
smoke there's fire Harvard tried to
cover for her by essentially waving it
off as gays Mal the malfant say just an
oversight that could be corrected
remember they said it was just instances
of inadequate citation well those
instances neared the number 50 yesterday
not just a few words here or there oh
unless you think lifting full paragraphs
from another author's Work is cool I
guess 50 must have been the magic number
though because today claudian Gay
resigned as president but when you read
her statement she doesn't at all sound
remorseful for or even she doesn't
mention her
plagiarism but predictably she plays the
race card claiming that she's been
subjected to personal attacks and
threats fueled by racial
animus well that was exactly what the
media was waiting for and the racial
arsonist himself Al Sharpton said this
is an attack on every black woman in the
country who's put a crack in the glass
ceiling and then there was CNN's Jake
Tapper I don't think it's fair to say
all of her critics were racist but
certainly a few of them were there are
people who have come straight out and
said that they believe that Claudine gay
was only appointed because she's black
because she's a woman but especially
because she's black I can't even imagine
what she's had to face okay what she
faced what about all the candidates she
beat out for the top job at Harvard who
didn't
plagiarize and perhaps whose academic
work was not steeped in victimology and
infused with what seems to be a twisted
racial
Obsession look I I said this from the
beginning it was clear from the get-go
that this controversy left unaddressed
would eventually devour Harvard and it
practically did of course hiring her in
the first place was their first grave
mistake and that has nothing to do with
Race by the way thank you very much and
everything to do with basic competence
basic
achievement gay resignation tells us a
lot about the rot that runs deep in some
American universities and importantly it
tells us that the hard left isn't strong
enough to protect its own people no
matter how high up they get and if you
see a hard-left person in a prestigious
job it's not because the hard left put
him there it's because the rich people
who run the nation's major institutions
want them there and until today the
Harvard Corporation the board of
overseers and most of the schools
well-connected uh very public big donors
wanted Claud Dean gay to stay as
president now people like Bill Amman
well he was one of the
exceptions but once the herd changed its
mind whenever that was well she didn't
last
long in America only populists have the
energy and the wherewithal to stand up
to the rich everyone else including the
hardle and the so-called moderate
Republicans they either go along with
the rich or eventually they get crushed
so now the question is how many other
Claudine gays are there in
Academia answer if you have that many
fingers I think you were created in a
lab or something any Professor or
administrator of any color or any
background doesn't need to be caught
plagiarizing to be occupying an office
that he or she never deserved and the
IVs aren't suddenly going to stop being
woke because of one
resignation Jay Larry Jameson you might
not know him but he was the man chosen
as the interim president by upen when it
can Liz McGill now he's been with the
school since 2011 serving as its
Executive Vice President for the health
system and the dean of the Perman School
of
Medicine well here's what he's been up
to since coming to
Penn after Co and George Floyd he made a
point to ditch the traditional standards
of excellence and Merit that he expect
in a medical school and put a focus on
Dei trying to make pen medicine
anti-racist Equitable diverse and
inclusive in June 2021 he promised
cultural transformation at Penn Medicine
and later he talked about the importance
of rooting out racism there are risk to
broadening our selection criteria but
there also risk to not embracing more
diverse groups of future
Physicians Innovation and diversity are
symbiotic partners I hope and I believe
that we have reached an inflection point
in the effort to root out racism and
bias in
medicine last year's widespread outrage
over racial Injustice has catalyzed an
ongoing movement to affect enduring
change oh my
gosh there's so much to say about this
man but of course this all has to mean
that medicine at its core must be racist
too embracing diversity and inclusion
will help us evolve more quickly and
successfully more diverse caregivers are
essential to build trust in our
profession and this trust can accelerate
closing Health
disparities oh well the other schools
still have a shot here learn from this
lose the woke and go For Broke on Merit
on excellence and objective Talent
there's a lot of it out there from every
racial background ethnicity you'll be
doing everyone a favor and you'll be
ending the tyrannical grip of the racial
spoil system that's poisoned so much of
American society and that's the angle
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else